Welcome back to human emotion.
So what we know about emotion so far is that it's a common ingredient of really
what makes us human.
It enables us to adaptively respond in the face of stress and enables us to
pursue some of our most important life goals.
So in all these ways we know emotions are not only good for us,
but they help us function.
They help us survive in our everyday life.
But what happens when emotions go awry?
Can they go awry?
And when they do,
what does it look like and how can we understand it?
So here what we're thinking about is delving into the realm of emotional
disorders to look at all the different themes we've talked about so far in terms
of what an emotion is,
the way that it's measured across subjective behavioral and physiological
channels,
and looking at the ways in which things may break down and what exactly it looks
like when they do so.
It's no surprise in many ways that we see emotion intimately involved in many of
our most prominent and well known clinical disorders.
And in fact,
as you can see here,
we have an entire field that's devoted to the study of emotion and mental
illness or emotion in psychopathology.
We see entire volumes here dedicated to understanding emotions like pathology,
looking at emotion regulation and psychopathology,
and even handbooks of emotion regulation with specific chapters devoted
exclusively to a variety of different disorders.
So it's clear that this concept of emotion regulation and emotion gone awry is
gaining increasing momentum.
Indeed,
if you look here,
what we see if we go across a host of different common mental disorders is that
one of the core features of each of them is emotion.
So let me show you what I mean.
So here you can see a variety of disorders,
many of them common to you or that you may have heard about in your other
courses or in the news.
And what you see on the right is that the core feature associated with many of
these disorders are emotions at heart.
So we have sadness and guilt that feature and major depressive disorder fear
that feature centrally in specific phobia,
panic disorder,
and even social phobia,
which also includes feelings of excessive embarrassment.
Um,
if we think about bipolar disorder here at the bottom,
we see that it's associated with feelings of anger and recent accounts that
discuss it in terms of also potentially being associated with too much
happiness.
So what's really important as we think about this idea of emotion gone awry is
to be very careful to not necessarily assume that in any of these emotional
disorders,
that means that their emotional makeup is inferior.
And I love this quote here by Hans Asperger,
who was a pediatrician from the Ena who first notice the early signs of autism
spectrum disorders who made this point where he said that not everything that
steps out of line and thus abnormal must necessarily be inferior.
And this is a theme I want to take through this journey into understanding how
emotion goes awry,
to try to understand the ways in which it may be different,
but to not assume that different necessarily means inferior.
So we're going to start our first section today of our three modules looking at
emotional disorders.
And we'll start today by looking at the nature of sadness and fear.
And in particular today we're really going to hone in on this concept of fear
and anxiety and think about the ways in which perhaps someone could experience
too much fear and what does that mean and what does it look like and which
disorders do we know might be associated with heightened or excessive fear?
So the themes that we're going to follow today are as follows.
So I'm going to start out with some of the three key themes that really
characterize the ways in which emotion can go awry in psychological disorders.
Next we're going to compare what is the distinction between fear versus anxiety.
Then we're going to delve into,
um,
a variety of different anxiety disorders and try to precisely pinpoint how,
when and where has emotion gone awry.
Then we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and our expert interview.
So let's first start with some of these key themes.
And again,
these are the themes that we take from a basic aspect of science perspective and
apply to the study of psychopathology.
To characterize broadly what are the different ways that emotion can go awry.
So this is a framework that I developed with a colleague of mine,
Dacher Keltner,
and we outlined three major central themes.
So the first theme when we think of emotion and psychopathology is this theme of
extremes.
So here you can see it's defined as a greater intensity of emotional displays
and a greater amplitude of emotional reactivity.
Essentially what we're seeing here is that in some instances what might be going
on is that individuals are experiencing too much of a given emotion,
that the intensity is at a heightened level that's causing them difficulty.
So we'll delve into this later today when we talk about maybe the idea of having
too much fear and anxiety disorders.
The second thing,
which was sort of complimentary is this idea of absences.
So you can see here this is defined as having a lower intensity of emotional
displays,
or maybe they're even absent altogether,
and a decreased amplitude of emotional activity that also may be absent.
So here by contrast,
what we're looking at is whether or not there are key disorders that actually
involve less of an emotion that you then you'd want to see,
or perhaps the emotion is all together,
gone,
are absent.
And then finally,
the third key theme of how emotion can go Orion psychopathology is this notion
of disjunction.
So we talked about earlier in the course how emotions have multiple components,
right?
They have an experiential component and outward expressive behavioral display
and a physiological response component.
And ideally,
as we talked about in this course,
these channels really cohere together.
They're bound together,
and a given emotion should have some flavor manifested in all these channels.
However,
in some clinical disorders,
what we're going to see is a disjunction where these channels don't line up
anymore,
they're sort of mismatched,
are at odds with one another.
And that this can give rise to many of the difficulties we see in major and
severe psychological disorders.
So I want you to keep these three themes in mind as we delve through a variety
of different emotional disorders to think about exactly how,
when and why emotion goes awry.
So let's start first by differentiating what is fear from anxiety.
Now many of you may think of these things as synonyms or you know,
perhaps use them interchangeably.
What I want to show you now is actually the important ways in which fear and
anxiety are actually two related,
but really fundamentally distinct kinds of phenomena.
So when we think about fear to begin,
what is the function of fear?
And here what we're going to do is take our traditional sort of evolutionary
account to think about what is the adaptation that fear confers?
What good is it for us?
Why do we have it in the first place?
So this is very familiar with what we spoke about at the beginning of the term
when we talked about what is an emotion and went through some of the six basic
emotions,
including fear.
So just as a reminder,
I mean fear.
What we see here in this slide is that it's in response to a recurrent
evolutionary situation.
So we have some sort of signal of threat,
maybe it's hearing the Q associated with a Predator associated with this.
We see automatic shifts in perception and attention.
We become more attentive to potentially threat related sounds and we're much
more like the perceived threats within our environment.
The goal of fears ultimately to preserve safety and keep us very present,
focused in the moments that we can immediately,
you know,
divert from potential threat related cues and remain safe.
So this triggers a fight or flight response.
We see increased blood flow to the periphery,
increased oxygen volume,
and all of this is really geared towards helping us defend ourselves against
potential threats and escape potential predators.
Okay,
so this is the function of fear.
Now,
how is fear different from anxiety?
So here's,
we just talked about fear.
On the left,
it's present focused.
It's proximal to an eliciting stimulus,
meaning it's really in response to an immediate threat in a given moment,
right?
So it triggers your sympathetic nervous system fight or flight response.
Um,
and it can often happen automatically or subconsciously and associated with
things like the Amygdala,
right?
This sort of what people often used to think of is the fear center of the brain
or something that's really about salience in the environment.
Now this is actually really different from anxiety.
So if you look here on the right,
what you see with anxiety is that anxiety is actually not about the present at
all.
It's really your future oriented state.
You're thinking about things that may be or could happen or you're worrying
about happening some place off in the future,
right?
So it doesn't have this sort of immediate or proximal stimulants.
It's actually about some future threat.
And what it does is it increases this sort of sense of getting prepared and
mobilizing for some aversive outcome.
That's about to happen,
but it has not yet happened.
Um,
and by contrast,
it's usually not always subconsciously activated.
These are often kinds of feelings and cognitions we're having quite consciously
as we think about what might be happening in the future.
So,
for example,
you may be thinking about,
um,
if you,
you know,
live here in new haven about a storm that we knew that was coming right and sort
of getting mobilized for that of all the things you can do to be prepared for a
potential threat that's about to happen.
Um,
so what I want to think about now as we've compared fear and anxiety is when are
these emotions actually useful for us?
Right?
We talked about a functional account of fear.
What about anxiety when his anxiety actually helpful?
So there's four things here.
You can see that sort of detail the ways in which anxiety can actually be good
for us,
right?
It's not always bad.
So first anxiety facilitates planning for the future.
So it helps people do things like,
you know,
put in the energy needed to apply for med school,
for example.
Um,
second,
it also helps recruit help from other people.
So when you express or exhibit anxiety,
what this does is it elicits a prosocial response from other people.
You can probably readily imagine a time you told a friend you were worried about
something.
And often that will bring in comfort from other people.
Third,
it is associated with a vigilance to threat.
So this helps increase your attention to potential dangers in the environment.
So if you're in sort of an anxious mind state,
you're going to be more likely to be attentive to cues of potential threats to
your safety,
such as maybe watching for pedestrians when you're driving,
for example.
And finally,
the fourth point here is that it enhances a up to a certain level,
physical and intellectual performance.
So again,
when we have some anxiety actually mobilizes us to approach goals and give us
the energy we need to overcome them.
So those are some ways in which anxiety can actually be helpful.
Now,
when his anxiety harmful by contrast,
so there's many ways in which too much anxiety or experienced in the wrong
context may actually be harmful for us.
So first we can see here that sometimes when anxiety's experienced to an
extreme,
it can hinder social functioning.
So having an extreme fear of public speaking,
for example,
can get in the way of many domains of life from class presentations to um,
particular jobs,
which really require you to speak,
uh,
and interact in front of crowds.
Second,
it impedes basic tasks of living.
So people who may have anxiety or fear of flying,
for example,
might not be able to take vacations they need to do or go to conferences or just
travel the world,
you know,
fulfill some of their life dreams.
Third,
it can also cause physical harm.
So we'll talk about OCD or obsessive compulsive disorder where an extreme
anxiety over contamination actually leads people to wash their hands up to the
point that their hands actually start bleeding from being sort of overexposure
alleviated.
Um,
it can lead even to death.
So in the case of eating disorders like Anorexia Nervosa,
this anxiety or fear of becoming fat,
I can actually lead people to restrict their caloric intake to the point of
starvation.
And then finally,
it increases risks for other Comorbid or coal company emotional disorders.
So,
um,
we see anxiety,
often coker with heart disease,
substance abuse and even suicidal ideation and behaviors that can be very
harmful,
um,
when experience too in Tennessee or in the wrong context.
So what I want to turn now to is what I think of as the broad umbrella of
anxiety disorders.
So when we think about this umbrella,
we can start at a certain point and sort of diverged out.
And what we see here and we'll walk through a few of these today,
is that anxiety disorders come in many different flavors,
ranging from phobias to panic disorder,
two generalized anxiety disorder,
obsessive compulsive disorder,
post traumatic stress disorder and social anxiety disorder.
And importantly in what you can see at the bottom of the slide here is that
they're extremely common.
So they're the most common psychiatric disorder and have a prevalence in the
general population of 25%.
So one out of four people at some point in their life has had one of these
anxiety disorders.
So perhaps you,
yourself or someone you know,
has experienced one of these,
um,
umbrella anxiety disorders.
So what I want to do then is walk through this umbrella with a couple key
examples of anxiety disorders and how we might think of this from a basic
emotion perspective.
We're an aspect of science perspective.
So let's start first on the left here with specific phobias.
Um,
in fact,
these are the most common of all psychiatric disorders.
There's hundreds of them potentially,
and they have a high prevalence and they can be extremely debilitating.
So what we see here is what's called the Dsm or diagnostic and statistical
manual of mental disorders criteria for specific phobia.
So what it involves is a marked and persistent fear of some specific object or
situation.
And importantly,
if you have a phobia,
you are always anxious when you're presented with that particular stimulus.
So let's say you have a fear of flying.
You always feel anxious when you're,
you know,
seeing pictures of planes where you're thinking about taking a flight or you're
actually on a plane.
Importantly,
and this is a really unique part of the phobias,
is having some degree of insight of recognizing that the fear that you have is
excessive.
In other words,
it's more fear than most people would have in that situation.
Maybe we're all a little nervous about flying.
Maybe we all feel a little uncomfortable around snakes.
But the idea here is that the kind of fear that you would have if you had a
phobia of these things would be much at a much greater degree and excessive.
Um,
fourth,
you can see here as this idea of avoidance.
So you try to avoid these situations.
You try to avoid flying,
avoid snakes,
or if you have to encounter it,
you endure it with severe distress.
Um,
and importantly with all clinical disorders,
um,
they must cause impairment in your life.
They must get in the way of achieving your personal goals,
um,
or daily life tasks.
That's a critical part of phobias is that they get in the way of us achieving
our functional goals.
Um,
so there's all different kinds of phobias.
You could probably name a phobia for everything in the world.
Um,
but these are sort of the kind of five most common categories of phobias.
so there's animal phobias.
Often you see snakes,
spiders,
dogs,
there's what's called natural environment phobias.
So these are phobias of fear,
fear of heights,
fear of storms,
fear of water.
A really common one is blood injection,
injury phobia.
So,
um,
many people can relate to feeling extremely uncomfortable and they have to get a
shot,
get blood drawn or undergo different medical procedures.
And this is not a joke in any way.
This can actually really impede with persons ability to seek much needed medical
treatment,
um,
that they need because they're so afraid of encountering needles are seeing
blood.
Um,
then there's situational phobias.
And again,
these are just some examples.
Fear of tunnels,
bridges,
elevators.
Um,
so my background is a clinical psychologist.
I have actually worked with patients who had phobias of elevators and worked
with them to sort of encounter elevators to try to overcome their fears.
But it's actually a quite common phobia,
is feeling afraid of elevators of being contained in a close space.
We also see flying,
driving close spaces and then there's this general kind of fifth category of
other phobias.
So this really does mean other,
so choking illness,
loud sounds.
Um,
but importantly there can be a phobia of pretty much anything you can think of.
and importantly,
what I want to show you here is that,
and it's something I highlighted earlier,
is that phobias are incredibly common,
right?
So if you look at just generally across the population at any one given time
point,
you have 11% of people who are reporting some kind of specific phobia and you
can then see here that it goes down from animals,
heights,
blood all the way down to storms.
So this is something that I think is really interesting because it's something
that many of us have experienced of having an excessive fear of something that
by itself actually would make many people uncomfortable.
But there's this degree of extreme responsivity in some people to certain
objects or situations.
Um,
and like I said,
you know,
I just gave some examples earlier,
phobias,
but you can find,
there's actually some websites that list all different kinds of phobias you
could think of.
And these are some that come up.
So,
um,
some of these that I think are quite interesting,
RM,
Gina Phobia or access,
fear of knees.
Um,
you also have,
I think that's a less common one.
Um,
there's a,
I can never say this on Sam.
Hina phobia,
a fear of Halloween.
You have metro phobia,
fear of poetry.
Um,
and then you have,
um,
Zam the phobia,
the color yellow.
So I'm wearing yellow today and we have yellow slides.
Hopefully none of you have that particular phobia in the audience right now.
Um,
but the point is like,
really you can find a phobia for anything out there.
There's no limitation to what can or can not be a phobia.
Um,
now how do you treat phobias?
How do you get someone who has this excessive fear of a particular object?
Maybe it's the color yellow or maybe it's Halloween.
How do you get them to sort of,
kind of bring down that level of fear?
So there's,
um,
kind of different ways that people will go about it.
Who are psychotherapists often they're called cognitive behavioral therapists.
Um,
and what the essential ingredient is,
is to expose people.
As you can see here to the feared situation of the object.
Essentially what you're putting them through is probably the most uncomfortable
kind of therapy one could imagine because you're having them encounter the very
thing that makes them feel the most fearful of anything else.
So there's different ways of exposing people.
You can have the mentally visualize it.
So may be thinking of an image of a snake or thinking of the color yellow.
You can do these virtual reality exposures that you can see in the bottom left
photo there where they actually have devised these amazing simulated um,
computerized,
um,
exposures to spiders where the person will put on a camera mass just like that
young man there.
And you'll actually be able to see,
spiders have actually reached out as if you were touching one.
And then in vivo exposure is really the real deal.
So if it were a spider or snake,
actually going in and touching a spider or snake live,
um,
and you can do this in different ways.
You can just do it all at once.
Sort of flood the person with the most fearful object in that category.
They can think of,
or you can do what's called the gradual hierarchy,
sort of taking baby steps,
one at a time at a time,
a picture of a snake to movie of the snake to virtual reality,
to Nvivo.
Um,
interestingly,
the more you expose yourself to something you're afraid of,
the less afraid you become.
So as difficult as it is,
it's an incredibly effective short term treatment for curing phobia's.
Um,
the next one we'll briefly talk about is panic disorder.
So panic disorders.
Interesting.
So if we peek into the DSM again,
so looking at what is the diagnostic criteria for panic disorder,
you'll see very similar,
um,
uh,
criteria for phobias at the bottom and so far as it causes impairment.
But what you're seeing for panic disorder here is that first you have to first
have had a history of a panic attack.
So panic attack is this discrete period of intense fear.
So out of nowhere,
people often report feeling out of the blue,
this intense feeling of fear,
almost a fight or flight response that'll hit right away and peak within 10
minutes.
So essentially what's happening is your body is physiologically telling you that
there's something in the environment that you need to either fight or flight or,
or would they call,
flee or,
or sort of,
um,
you know,
fight against.
So suddenly your body's just gearing up your heart's racing,
you're sweating,
you're dizzy.
And what's important is that not all people who have panic attacks develop panic
disorder.
So it's only those people who have panic attacks,
but then develop a fear of having future panic attacks.
Almost a fear of these physiological sensations right here.
Those are the individuals who we talk about as having panic disorder.
And I often think of this in terms of an equation.
So what is panic disorder?
So first you have had the first ingredient,
which is a panic attack,
right?
Which has all these physiological symptoms right here,
heart racing,
dizziness,
feeling like you're feigning nausea,
plus a fear of future panic attacks,
which then equates to panic disorder.
So the way that I often think of panic disorders as this quote by Franklin d
Roosevelt who said,
the only thing we have to fear is fear itself.
And I think really this is the heart of what panic disorder is.
Cause in the sense what is happening is there's a fear of fear,
right?
So it's this idea that you become afraid of your body's natural signals that
correspond to feeling fearful.
So I broke this up into three parts here.
So this is called the fear of fear hypothesis.
So part one is that you have this overly aroused,
kind of physiological,
autonomic nervous system response that we talked about earlier in class.
Second is that you have a tendency to become distressed or uncomfortable by
physical sensations in your body.
Your heart racing makes you feel really,
uh,
you know,
not at ease.
And then part three is what starts to be the vicious cycle that leads to panic
disorder.
You worry about having future panic attacks.
This worry then heightens and even gets your heart racing even faster.
And it actually makes it more likely that you're going to have a future panic
attack.
The more you get revved up and tuned into your body's own sensations.
Now,
panic disorder interestingly can also coker with something called the Gore
phobia.
So you can have panic disorder with or without this thing called the Gore
Now what a Gore for via really refers to is it gets at this idea of behavioral
avoidance.
So people often worry about having panic attacks and things like crowds.
So in lines,
buses,
trains,
or situations essentially that a resent representing to them that they have no
escape,
no way to get out should they have a panic attack.
And when you have that put together,
you have what's called the Gore phobia.
So this is often called fear of the marketplace.
It's where the term originates from.
And what it refers to is people who are often in closing themselves in their
houses because they're so afraid of going outside to be in some place where they
might have a panic attack and they might not be able to escape or get out of
that situation.
So this is the Gore phobia.
And as you might imagine,
it's an incredibly debilitating,
a psychiatric disorder for many who suffer.
Okay.
We're going to quickly now turned to generalized anxiety disorder,
Gad,
followed by obsessive compulsive disorder.
So for Ga di,
when we peek into the DSM,
what we're seeing here is a kind of anxiety that's more generalized,
more widespread.
So you see chronic and persistent warrior tension that lasts at least six months
and people have extreme trouble controlling their worry.
It's very hard to stop it or decrease it.
And you have a lot of associated symptoms like trouble concentrating,
fatigue intention.
So really what we're seeing is people who are in a constant state of sort of
hypervigilance and worry,
we see a two to one female to male ratio and Gad and often has a very chronic
course with very low rates of remission.
So an example you might see here as a woman with JD who would say,
I always thought I was just a worrier.
I'd feel keyed up and unable to relax.
At times it would come and go and at times it would be constant.
It could go on for days I'd worry about what I was going to fix for a dinner
party or what would be a great present for somebody.
I just couldn't let go.
So the idea that people have talked about when they think about JD is that
they're engaging in worry as a way to avoid feelings of anxiety,
right?
So this is a avoidance perspective on worry.
So in some ways,
um,
what they,
what people like Bork Avec would hypothesize is that you have more thoughts than
images when you worry and worry actually restricts your ability to become
physiologically aroused and even distances you from an emotional state.
So in some ways this chronic worrying and gid may actually help decrease the
physical and emotional intensity in the short term,
but that worrying,
even though you're distancing from your emotions causes long term difficulties.
Um,
Doug Mennin,
a colleague of mine who used to be at,
yeah,
developed an emotion regulation model of GED where he posited four main features
of emotion dysregulation.
And this disorder,
the first is heightened intensity of emotions.
So people with JD or have very quick emotional reactions there,
they're quick,
they come on easy and they're intense.
They also have a poor understanding of their own emotions.
So they have trouble identifying emotions like anger,
discuss joy and emotions to them.
Feel very confusing,
kind of very diffused.
They can't make sense of them as easily and they also have third a negative
reactivity to their own feelings.
So they feel when they experience emotions,
the emotions they experience our immersive and they have trouble accepting them
when they occur.
And finally,
I'm Doug men and would say that there's a maladaptive management of emotions.
They either under regulate their emotions or they try to overregulate them and
control or suppress,
so they're really having trouble making sense of their emotions and effectively
managing or regulating them,
which we talked about earlier in class.
Finally,
I'm just going to turn to obsessive compulsive disorder for today,
but I recommend you also check out PTSD and social anxiety and think about the
ways they also may represent excessive or heightened fear.
So for OCD,
if we peek into the DSM again,
what we see the core criteria as having two parts.
One part our obsessions,
so these are intrusive,
unwanted,
uncontrollable thoughts and images.
They're thoughts that people see as irrational,
but yet they can't control them and they can often include sort of sexual
themes,
themes of aggression or contamination.
Then there's the behavioral component on the,
on the right.
So these are compulsion's.
So these are the repetitive behaviors and rituals that people can't stop doing.
So this is washing your hands again and again,
this is counting up to a certain number.
This is cleaning,
checking,
double checking,
locking doors,
you know,
checking the oven.
And these compulsions are really interesting because in the moment they
temporarily relieve fear.
They cause people to feel better just for a brief moment,
but they don't last very long.
So they're unsuccessful emotion regulation strategies and the compulsion will
come up again even just seconds later.
So people are kind of caught in this recursive repetitive loop trying to assuage
their anxiety with these unusual compulsive behaviors and not having a very
successful experience doing so in the long term.
Um,
many of you may have seen OCD in the media and movies like the aviator or as
good as it gets.
I'm depicting some of these ritualistic behaviors that people are doing as a way
to try to ease their anxiety,
but they're ultimately unsuccessful and caused them a lot of impairments
socially.
And even to the point that people can physically isolate themselves from the
world.
So this is the umbrella we talked about today.
And if we think about what are the most common treatments for anxiety disorders,
they can include medication.
Often antidepressants are benzodiazepines.
There's behavioral treatments that we talked about,
um,
as well as cognitive behavioral treatments that help people work on some of that
maladaptive behaviors or some of the,
um,
excessive negative thinking that may trigger anxiety.
We also talked about this idea of exposing people are systematically
desensitizing them to the very thing they're afraid of.
So having them go in and confront what it is that makes them feel the most
anxious.
There's also therapies that are called panic control therapy.
And at the bottom,
what's gained a lot of attention recently is this idea of mindfulness and
acceptance.
So this is one example of a workbook that I've used with my own clients and the
mindfulness and acceptance workbook for anxiety,
which is really teaching you not to fight against your anxiety,
to sort of let go of the struggle and simply accept what you're feeling.
And through acceptance,
it may actually decrease the anxiety altogether.
Um,
so this has gained a lot of increasing momentum in terms of a way to treat
really chronic,
really severe anxiety difficulties.
So with that,
we'll conclude with our takeaway questions.
So the first question for today says,
well,
what were the three broad themes that we discussed that describe the
relationship between emotion and psychopathology?
Second,
what were the key distinctions that we discussed between fear and anxiety?
And last,
can you describe the core emotion related difficulties in the four key anxiety
disorders that we reviewed today?
As well as think about how these might apply to other anxiety disorders we
didn't touch on today,
such as PTSD or social anxiety disorder.
And finally,
I'll conclude with our expert interview.
And again,
this is part of the experts in emotion interview series at Yale University.
So today for our expert interview,
um,
we have the pleasure of speaking with Dr Doug men and who's going to share his
thoughts on anxiety and emotion.
So doctor men and received his phd from Temple University and after nine years
on the faculty at Yale University,
he joined the Department of Psychology at Cuny.
Hunter College is an associate professor,
Dr men and has focused on treating chronic bouts of anxiety and mood disorders
and his work examines first the experimental and ecological delineation of
behavioral and biological processes that contribute both to emotion reactivity
and dysregulation and chronic anxiety as well as co-occurring depression.
Second,
he looks at the development of an integrative mechanism based emotion regulation
treatment,
which has demonstrated considerable efficacy thus far,
especially in the realm of generalized anxiety disorder.
And finally,
he also examines biobehavioral mechanisms of reactivity and dysregulation,
who's changes mediate longterm symptomatic and functional outcome as a result of
this intervention in his work,
Dr men and utilizes experimental paradigms centered on presenting emotional
stimuli in context to individuals with pathological chronic anxiety and
depression.
Has Research has been funded by several organizations and institutes,
including the National Institute of Mental Health and he's published over 60
peer reviewed empirical articles and book chapter,
as well as editing two books.
His work has been recognized by numerous awards,
including the president's Fund for Faculty Advancement Award and the George and
Shuster Faculty Fellowship Fund from Cuny Hunter College,
as well as the senior faculty fellowship and the Social Sciences from Yale
University doctor Ben,
and currently serves on the editorial board of several major journals and on the
executive board of the APA division of clinical psychology and the society for a
science of clinical psychology and as a member of the Scientific Council of the
Anxiety Disorders Association of America.
So I now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with Doctor Doug
Mennin.
Okay.